Ava Roden David what situations do you
think bring out the absolute worst in
people I have you a few thoughts on this
I mean colloquially in the sort of
day-to-day life delays and breakdowns of
systems that we take for granted often
bring out the really bad in people so
like in when I lived in New York City
the subway generally worked really
really well and on those rare occasions
where there would be crazy snow and the
subways would be delayed inordinately I
would show up to the subway station and
the entire platform was just a mass of
people and five six trains would go by
and people are pushing and shoving
people are becoming very very physically
aggressive you try to leave and go
outside to maybe walk and take a
different subway line or whatever and
everybody is just fending out there
basically fending for themselves and
very very quickly when a system that we
take for granted breaks down people get
very very that they become their worst
version of themselves and following this
if you've got an emergency or a serious
calamity an interruption to the food
supply long-term power outages you will
often see the worst brought out in
people but also you sometimes see the
best brought out in people and when you
look at what happened in Puerto Rico
after the series of hurricanes included
cleaning Hurricane Maria sama and you
saw a lot of the worse than people
brought out but you also saw a lot of
the best in people and people really
rallying together now I would argue that
the longer it goes in bad situations the
breakdown of some of those systems we
take for granted you would see more and
more of the worse than people brought
out sadly I think it's just kind of
human nature and then another one is a
state situations a state ones when
someone dies and their estate goes into
I guess what you would call going into
probate you see a lot of the worst in
people brought out family members
starting to tear at each other
figuratively and sometimes literally
relationships ruined over appeals to
and contesting of wills and I have seen
and I know a lot of estate attorneys
estate situations will very often bring
out just the absolute bottom of the
barrel worse than people and sometimes
it's also not the estate part because
deaths and families can really sometimes
create such a calamitous situation that
it is really really bad for a long time
it can get extraordinarily
extraordinarily ugly and it's horrible
and I don't know what you can do to to
prevent that and that kind of gets to
money in general right like when you get
to what what's that what's a common
thread between estate situations and
power going out and people having to
live off of the resources that they've
accumulated before that time if you have
a food supply interruption or whatever
it really gets down to money and this is
not like a money is the root of all evil
thing it's just money situations can
bring out the worst in people and often
when there are no longer consequences
for actions I think that you often see
the worst brought out in people that's
not a religious argument it's not you
need God in order to keep people moral
the the consequences for actions can be
societal they can be law enforcement or
whatever when people and it doesn't
often happen when when you do have
circumstances where people at least
perceive that there might not be
consequences to their actions or there
might be limited consequences to actions
that often also brings out really really
bad things in people we've got a great
bonus show for you today I'm out of time
we've got great programming continuing
after the David Pakman show staff
vacation which we will be in next week